[Music]
foreign
[Music]
start with this so you might have seen
AI in a bunch of forms all over social
media lately like I have whether it's
making AI art or doing AI portraits or
AI chat Bots having conversations and
writing poems and all kinds of crazy
stuff like that so I have a lot of
questions about it but naturally I
immediately went to the top of the most
existential pyramid of questions which
is just
can this AI eventually replace me now
before we get started I just want to
make it clear that I am not saying AI
can't do amazing things in fact AI
algorithms and machine learning models
are capable of some truly impressive
Feats but when it comes to creating
content online
there are some fundamental reasons why
AI can't replace human creators first
let's define what we mean by online
Creator at its core being an online
Creator is a creative process right so
it involves coming up with ideas
developing content publishing it online
engaging with an audience and this
process requires imagination and
creativity and a human perspective on
the other hand AI is a machine learning
technology it's not capable of
imagination or creativity it doesn't
have a human perspective instead it's a
tool designed to process data and
perform specific tasks in conclusion AI
might be able to perform some impressive
tasks but it can't replace online
creators because it's not capable of
imagination
creativity and a human perspective it's
a tool not a creator
you wouldn't want to listen to an entire
video created by an AI would you
except you just did because every word
that I just read to you came directly
from asking open ai's AI chat bot called
chat GPT to write a script for an MKBHD
video on why AI can't replace online
creators and I simply just recited it
it's fascinating though isn't it I just
did a video earlier this year on Dolly
another project also by openai where you
input a text prompt and it spits out a
realistic high resolution new unique art
piece and whatever style you want and
the art pieces are surprisingly detailed
and realistic and it's accurate to the
words you gave it it's such a powerful
tool and so now this other tool by open
AI is also going viral and it's more
along the lines of a robot you can talk
to a chat bot so it's called chat GPT
and it's capable of holding a
conversation back and forth about almost
anything and so you can kind of have a
normal conversation with it right now
but the types of things people are
asking of it are getting increasingly
more and more complex you can ask it for
some fact
or you can ask it for the summary of a
book or you can have it write a poem for
you or ask it to find an error in some
code or clearly just ask it to write a
whole script for a YouTube video it is
incredibly impressive what it's been
able to do just kind of drawing from the
database of all of human knowledge and
then having intricate detailed nuanced
conversations with people on a variety
of topics so here's my actual real human
take on the emergence of these new AI
tools two things one is that really is
just kind of amazing that we're living
through this time right now where we're
able to see these tools evolve in front
of our very eyes and get better and
better but two is just that that's all
it is is a tool in 2022 that's how I see
it it's just a really impressive tool so
I think the ideal use of this stuff
especially as like a Creator like me is
not to take my job but to use it as a
creative tool to sort of brainstorm
earlier in the process and then let me
put my human touch on top of it later
that's literally how I plan to use it so
you can ask chatgpt to help brainstorm
video ideas or even titles for these
videos and that's what it'll do but then
at the end of the day it'll be my human
judgment that decides what I actually
decide to publish so kind of like how
you might already use the AI subject
selection tool in Photoshop but then
refine the edges and the selection
yourself or you might use the AI
sharpening tool the AI enhanced tool in
pixelmator but then go go in and do the
rest of the edits to to Really match
your style so it's the beginning of the
process this new stuff we're seeing is
just the next level of that the only
difference here
is this stuff is a much more General Ai
and it is what we call a generative AI
meaning it creates things seemingly from
scratch so I think there will be people
who ask chat GPT for the summary of a
book and it can spit out an answer super
fast and you can use that as inspiration
for your own write-up I think there will
be college students that use it to
brainstorm an essay it won't be able to
actually spit out a finished essay for
you at this point but it is a pretty
damn good start like clearly this is an
amazing never before seen tool and it's
the start of something huge I'll even
continue to ask it for video script
ideas why not but just keep in mind when
I did it did say at the bottom that this
should be a starting point for a video
it didn't do any alliterations at the
end like I usually do and it did get
some facts wrong in the longer full
version as you can see and that actually
brings me to the dangers of something
like this of course with any massively
impactful new technology you have to at
least consider this type of stuff and
really two of of them have come to my
mind at the very top which are one the
error rate and two the complexity of
credit so I asked chat GPT to write a
script for an MKBHD review of the iPhone
14 pro and it made one and it's actually
pretty positive it goes over the specs
it calls the display bright and vibrant
and sharp perfect for watching movies
and playing games or browsing the web
and it calls it incredibly fast and
responsive I think that's true and it
says the standout new feature of this
year is the camera system I would agree
but then it says it has a 12 megapixel
Ultra wide a 12 megapixel wide and a 12
megapixel telephoto but as we know here
on the MKBHD channel the iPhone 14 pro
was the first one to actually have that
48 megapixel main camera
chat GPT was just wrong here and it also
shouted out the four colors silver gold
graphite and Pacific Blue
except those were the iPhone 12 Pros
colors this year there's a space black
and a new purple so chat GPT has a habit
of getting at least one thing wrong
every time you ask it something or at
least every time I asked something now
on the you know the whole six paragraph
video script thing like that's actually
pretty impressive the fact that it got
90 of that pretty pretty well but I also
asked the chat about something much more
simple what's the fastest sea mammal on
earth just curious and chat GPT said the
fastest sea mammal on earth is the
peregrine falcon although it is not a
sea mammal it is capable of reaching
speeds of over 240 miles an hour while
diving making it the fastest animal in
the world other fast sea mammals include
the sailfish which can swim at speeds up
to 68 miles per hour and the Orca which
can reach speeds of up to 34 miles per
hour now it's been a while since I've
been in school but I'm pretty sure only
one of those was a sea mammal and to be
fair it was is the correct answer it did
include the fact that an orca goes 34
miles an hour that is the right thing to
say but
clearly you can't rely on this thing to
be 100 factually accurate it's kind of
the same way there's also like a 90
accuracy rate with Dolly but it feels
more and more impressive the more
complex your prompts are like if you ask
dolly for a picture of a cat okay that's
pretty easy so it is kind of jarring
when it messes up some parts of
something that seems so easy and obvious
but when you ask for a cat wearing a
rocket booster jumping over a man
watering his garden in space it's like
okay it's kind of amazing what it's able
to generate from scratch to match the
description and then it's also not
shocking when maybe it gets one or two
of those things wrong kind of just like
that longer Essay with a few incorrect
facts I expect these error rates to go
down over time like that's kind of the
whole point of these AI models advancing
but you know that's something I'll keep
an eye on the other thing though is
credit and this is something you may
have seen pop up a little bit on social
media lately which is that AI steals art
without consent which here's what they
mean by that so the number one app in
the entire app store right now is
something called lensa AI by Prisma Labs
you might have seen some posts on your
timeline it's kind of blown up and the
basic premise is you pay a few bucks and
you upload a bunch of real photos of
your face give it a few minutes and the
black box of AI inside will spit out a
bunch of cool avatar characters that
look like you in a bunch of different
situations and has a bunch of different
characters some of them much better than
others I feel like it's kind of caught
fire lately because most people don't
typically have a bunch of cool art made
about them so like it's kind of neat
that you get to see that type of thing
but there's some other companies jumping
on this too uh Avatar AI is another one
so now you are technically consenting to
uploading your own face for it to be
used to train the models to put in these
images
but do you know who's not consenting to
have their art used for this type of
stuff
a lot of the artists who are also making
the art that's being fed in to inspire
these AI images the backgrounds the
materials the line work The Styling the
framing Etc here's something to keep an
eye on you know how most artists A lot
of them will sign like the bottom right
hand corner of their drawing or their
painting when they're done well one of
the telltale signs of potentially
copyrighted art being used by these AI
models without permission is a lot of
people are getting back from this app
with the mangled Recreations of a bunch
of different signatures because clearly
many of the source images that went into
it had signatures at the bottom like
that is wild so the unanswered question
right now is how do you give credit to
the artists whose work is being fed into
the machine that is creating AI art like
if I were to just ask dolly for a
picture of a cat it could easily just
spit out a brand new generic image of a
photorealistic cat and it's learned
through its models how to reproduce with
stable diffusion what an image of a cat
might look like inspired by
theoretically any image of a cat on the
internet that open AI is pulled in
actually technically it's learned from
the entire data set not just the images
of cats but basically I don't think any
artists would get too mad at that but
you can also ask Dali for a picture of a
cat in the style of Claude Monet and it
becomes much more clear what source
material is making it through to the
final input and if I was Monet and I was
still alive I probably wouldn't be too
happy with this now I'm not a copyright
lawyer so I'm not even going to try to
get into what counts as transformative
work or you know copyright infringement
what's not but the bottom line is we
don't actually really know the exact
totality of exactly where these AI
models are scraping from like there is
some general description sometimes if
you dig into it about publicly available
images and licensed content but there
are also some huge databases like
there's something called common crawl
that scrapes huge amounts of the
internet and creates a publicly
available free data set that anyone can
use it's called lion 5B and again not a
copyright layer but to me this kind of
feels like a bit of the loophole doesn't
it where technically common crawl
they're not profiting from anything
they're doing all the scraping of
billions and billions of things and then
putting it all in one place and then
it's available for free and then others
can decide what to do about that legal
stuff so open AI you know they were
using this data set and they were
initially doing all this stuff for free
but I think now it's like 15 bucks for a
set of 115 images something like that
but especially like the ones you fed
your face into the lenza one the Avatar
AI one they're just straight up charging
people they are making money
from the data sets that they just
crawled for free like think about it
this way here's a here's a simple
analogy if I were to make a YouTube
video and I want to use Taylor Swift
music in my YouTube video
that's actually fine as long as I don't
monetize my video so it's available for
free that's cool if someone else wants
to use a part of my video and they use
the part with the Taylor Swift music in
it can they make money off of that and
on YouTube there's already an answer to
this question which is no absolutely not
you cannot make money off that umg is
going to be coming after you in two
seconds flat but in this world of AI art
which is so new we kind of don't have an
answer to that yet like there is no
precedent set legally or culturally so
at the beginning it felt like the
biggest question was how do we Define
art this is crazy question but now it
feels like the more interesting question
actually is
what is inspiration exactly how do we
Define inspiration like when a human
draws something new of course it's a
unique expression entirely of their own
but of course they were also inspired by
previous drawings that they might have
seen in their life matter of fact they
are technically inspired by every moment
of their life leading up to the point
where the pen touches the paper and so
now ai art
basically just speed running inspiration
it's just like dumping all of recorded
human history into a black box and then
making something from it or maybe maybe
just everything that's in data set Lyon
5B which includes a ton of my own work
and thumbnails and images by the way but
at the end of the day if I'm being an
optimist which I try to be
I hope this makes us appreciate human
created art more for sure but we got to
keep an eye on all these unanswered
questions because there's a lot of them
and uh until then let the robots
rehearse the revolution you know it's
not an unanswered question though the
sponsor of this video karma karma is an
online shopping tool designed to help
you save money at your favorite stores
but how do they help you save money so
first it's not a crowdsourced coupon
depository it scans the entire internet
to find the best valid coupons for your
purchase and then apply as the best one
at checkout and then second if you're
creating a shopping list and something
is out of stock or you're like waiting
for it to come down in price is
something you like add it to Karma and
it will actually notify you when it's
back or when there's a price change it's
super easy and then lastly is karma cash
so you can get cash back at thousands of
stores and then once you earn enough you
can cash out with your PayPal account so
if you install it now they're giving a
special offer where you'll get double
the karma cash at sign up so get ten
dollars instead of five for a limited
time so the links Below in the video
description if you want to check that
out anyway until the next one thanks for
watching
catch you guys soon
peace